hey we've partnered with a company
called the dreamworld to bring you
exclusive anime merch that you can't
find anywhere else
we've got Mele Otis bond-esque Anor and
so much more check it out at enter
dreamworld com
or click the link in the description
what is up everybody its Anna Mack here
for anime uproar and today I will be
talking about the latest chapter of the
seven deadly sins manga and the apparent
ending of the series according to
sources that I'm seeing online chapter
345 is the second last chapter in
Chapter 346 the next chapter will be the
very last now in Chapter three four five
a ton of things happened and this
chapter itself feels like an ending on
its own we got a one and a half year
time skip we got major revelations about
the relationships and families of our
favorite characters and we got some new
characters heirs to the seven deadly
sins and they have been introduced by
name there is so much to talk about this
was definitely an iconic chapter for
every seven deadly sins fan so let's get
into it
if you enjoy our seven deadly sins
videos and you want us to keep it going
even after the manga ends please leave a
like to let me know and if you happen to
be new to anime uproar please don't
forget to subscribe and hit that
notification bell to turn on all
notifications whether you're new or you
just haven't turned the bell on yet
please consider turning it on because
that is the only way to get our videos
otherwise YouTube will bury them just
click subscribe click the bell and then
select the option that says all thank
you so much you could also hit me up on
Twitter and Instagram at anime uproar
for all the latest updates
finally this video will of course
contain seven deadly sins manga spoilers
we're talking about the very latest
chapters in the series perhaps the final
chapters so please proceed with caution
you have been warned on the cover page
of chapter three four five we see the
tiny hand of a baby grabbing the finger
of an adult and the adult is most likely
Mellie Otis the name of the chapter is
Ayers clearly implying that we are about
to be introduced to the next
duration of the seven deadly sins the
heirs of the original sins but more on
that later right off the bat we get an
18-month time skip the events of this
chapter are happening a year and a half
after the battle against the demon king
and so we can assume that both Elizabeth
and meliodas and bond and Elaine already
completed their planned trips across
Britannia we see Slater and a guy who
appears to be Simon from the dawn roar
noting how peaceful everything is now
and how all the missions that they have
to do such as capturing thieves or
defeating weak monsters pose almost no
challenge for them the holy nights
almost seem bored and disappointed at
how carefree their lives are although
this is probably better than having to
face demons again let alone the demon
king when I first saw that other holy
night with Slater I thought it might be
a long-haired Arden after the time-skip
but an older Arden and l3 appear later
on in the chapter so I guess this is
Simon with curlier hair during their
brief conversation it is made clear that
both holy Knights consider King Bhadra
to be the true king of Leona's and they
both seem to have an issue with Mele
Otis becoming the new king this is
presented as a mere passing comment
between them but it points to a deeper
issue there are probably thousands of
people throughout the kingdom of Leonys
who do not want to be ruled by a demon
and at the end of the day meliodas
is still a demon a demon who now rules
over a human kingdom as the chapter
continues this particular issue is
brought up again and in a big way
we then see our boy Hauser training with
Jericho and giya and both ladies seem to
have changed their hairstyles Hauser now
has a chin and neck beard but I'm not a
big fan of his facial hair how do you
grow a beard without growing a stylish
mustache
everyone knows that your power level is
multiplied by at least 10 or 20 times if
you happen to have a powerful mustache
just ask Lord s Kannur and the mighty
Lord Twigg Oh Houser is also revealed to
be the new Great Holy Night the leader
of all the holy Knights because let's
face it Gil Thunder angry amaura are
too busy keeping the royal princesses
happy if you know what I mean pora the
fairy then arrives to tell Jericho then
bond and Alain are about to have a baby
and Jericho excuses herself and Sprint's
over to the fairy Kings forest oh man
poor Jericho
she loves bond so much that she was able
to make her peace with the fact that
bond only loves Alain and now she is
genuinely excited for bond and Alain to
have a baby just try and tell me that
Jericho isn't a true hero this woman is
so underrated as a character she has
risked her life for bond she'd do
anything for him and she is even willing
to give up whenever being with him
because she loves him enough to let him
be happy with his true love even if that
person isn't her actually think of this
is really heroic in its own way and
Jericho deserves more credit and more
respect I'm looking at you Briggs
meanwhile death piers from the Pleiades
of the azure sky decides to leave Leonys
and his position as a diamond ranked
holy night death piers has decided to
dedicate his life to resurrecting the
kingdom of Edinburgh the kingdom that
had been destroyed by the vampire clan
so many years ago but there is more to
the reason why death Pierce has decided
to make this move as he explains to the
other Ezzor sky night after a demon
killed Denzel and after the goddess has
manipulated them death Pierce refuses to
serve a kingdom that has a demon as its
king and a goddess as its Queen death
Pierce is determined to restore
Edinburgh as a kingdom for humans and
humans alone again as with this later
scene naca bouzouki is using death peers
to tell us that this is not just a happy
ending for everyone there is still
conflict here the holy war may be
technically over but clearly there is a
large group of humans including
prominent holy Knights who deeply resent
both the demons and the goddesses and
who refused to be ruled by them death
pierce even wants to turn edinburgh into
a kingdom that is only for humans which
emphasizes that the days of
discrimination and interspecies conflict
may not be over yet
naca but didn't have to include these
scenes in this chapter he could have
just kept everything positive but he
deliberately chose to introduce this
conflict that is something to think
about
elsewhere we see that Dreyfuss has now
become a swordsmanship instructor and
Henriksen has become a potions master
with his own potions school it's a
pretty mediocre ending for these guys
although their brief conversation does
indicate that the next ruler after
meliodas has all but been decided which
is very interesting and in the next
scene we see King Bartra buying toys for
a little kid it turns out that he is
indeed buying toys for his future
grandchild
the child of Mellie Otis and Elizabeth
as marketing Gil Thunder and Veronica
Andrea Mora are being all lovey-dovey
with each other King Bartra reveals that
he already knows whether Mellie Otis and
Elizabeth are having a boy or a girl
thanks to one of his visions over into
fairy Kings forest all the fairies are
hilariously confused about what is going
on with Elaine she is pregnant with
bonds child but since this is the first
child ever to be conceived by a fairy
and a human and since fairies don't
actually give birth but are born from
nature itself
none of the fairies have any clue what
is going on inside Elaine's belly and I
thought that was pretty damn funny bond
and Elaine revealed that they have
already decided on a name for their
child and they both look extremely happy
about everything
poor sweet Elaine she has no idea what
she's in for
for her natural birth means baby fairies
growing like plants out of trees and
flowers but I'm afraid that with us
humans it's not quite so peaceful and
painless
best of luck Elaine I also thought that
it was very cool to see get had a
calling out to coccinea and ro and
telling them what a peaceful place the
world has become as you will remember
from the previous holy war get had and
the human ro kind of had a thing going
on before it all ended in tragedy so the
fact that she is now actually seeing
another fairy and another human loving
each other and having a child together
must be hard war
being forget holiday it is something
that she has been waiting for over 3,000
years to witness back in the onus Mellie
Otis is talking to a very pregnant
Elizabeth Elizabeth mentions that gal
Denzel Drew's had paid them a visit some
time ago and the two of them couldn't
believe that a demon and a goddess could
have a baby together although Elizabeth
is now part human so not just a goddess
I'm actually really glad that we got to
see gelda and zell dress again
even if it was just for one brief panel
I didn't want the manga to completely
forget about them like say oh I don't
know the freaking supreme deity so I did
appreciate this very brief shout out to
the hottest power couple of the
underworld Melly Otis then tells
Elizabeth that he has finally decided on
a name for the baby the baby's name will
be Tristan and it has also revealed that
the name of bonds baby will be Lancelot
this is in accordance with Arthurian
legend we're both Lancelot and tryst and
were knights of the round table who
served King Arthur of Camelot and they
were in fact the sons of Vaughan and
Mellie Otis respectively in Arthurian
legend both of them were men so it is
likely that the babies will be boys
although Merlin was supposed to be a man
in Arthurian legend and in the 7th of
these sins she is a woman so I guess you
never know is it just me or does this
really look like the setting up of a
next generation of the seven deadly sins
as if a continuation might really be
happening after all we already have King
Arthur Pendragon and together with
Merlin he has a quest to turn Camelot
into the perfect eternal Kingdom we now
also know that bonds son and melioidosis
son are going to be Lancelot and Tristan
two of King Arthur's knights of the
round table if I was knockabout and I
was trying to set up a sequel to the
seven deadly sins
I would definitely include the knights
of the round table in a prominent role
I mean Arthurian legend is just so cool
it has already influenced so much of the
seven deadly sins story and the knights
of the round table are absolutely iconic
I would love to see the knights of the
round table featured in a future seven
deadly sins story in whatever format
it might come I want to be clear that I
am NOT saying that a continuation is
definitely happening but this chapter
clearly sets up the possibility of a
continuation featuring Arthur Camelot
and the knights of the round table and
since this chapter introduced the idea
that some humans are rejecting Elizabeth
Emily Otis and wishing to form a human
only kingdom of their own
this means that NACA ba has already set
up a potential conflict that could be
explored in the continuation if there
ever is one at the very end of the
chapter Elizabeth speaks to the child
inside her belly and she tells him that
she hopes that he will have a wonderful
future ahead of him meanwhile Mellie
Otis looks out the castle window
he says his iconic SOT SOT SOT a and he
wonders what kind of future awaits again
if you wanted to set up a sequel or a
continuation what better way than to
introduce the next generation of the
characters include an overarching quest
with Arthur and Merlin introduce a
conflict featuring humans who reject
malleolus and Elizabeth and then end the
chapter with a heavy focus on the future
at this time there is no confirmation of
a sequel or continuation but with the
way that this ending has been written we
have to conclude that the door to such a
possibility has been left open I'm
actually considering making a separate
video that looks at Lancelot and Tristan
in Arthurian legend and speculates about
what kind of adventures they might have
if there is a seventh at least in sequel
if you'd like to see a video like that
please leave a like to let me know and
drop a comment informing me that you
want to see that video down in the
comments honestly as a final ending this
isn't bad at all in fact I really like
it a lot I love seeing the next
generation being born
I love the uncertainty about the future
and I love the prospect of seeing the
knights of the round table being
introduced as the heroes of the next
generation but as I mentioned in my
previous seven deadly sins video I would
have preferred that before all this
happens we actually got to see a fight
against the supreme deity personally I
would have made cath just a side villain
who leads up to the supreme deity and I
would have made chaos power the one
thing that can ultimately
feed the supreme deity this would have
given us a more satisfying final villain
and it would have explained why Merlin
was so obsessed with reviving the king
of chaos that would have made a lot more
sense to me than just ignoring the
supreme deity but hey that's my opinion
with that said I love that Lancelot and
Tristan two knights of the round table
are about to be born into the seven
deadly sins world as get had observed
the loving relationship between Elena
and bond is a symbol of how far we've
moved beyond the war and bloodshed of
the holy wars an meliodas and
Elizabeth's relationship is also a
symbol of this progress even though
things are not yet perfect and there is
still clear resentments between the
different clans and races important
progress has been made and most of our
favorite characters have undergone
tremendous development to be honest
Merlin is the only one of the sins who
still needs more development in my
opinion but I'm definitely not
complaining about this turn of events I
would have just like to see the lead up
to this type of ending unfold
differently it's funny back when I
collaborated with pro manga artist
Cuusoo mati to create a fictional son of
Mellie Otis and Elizabeth one of the
most popular name ideas for this
character was actually Tristan because
of Arthurian legend if you are
interested in what potential powers the
son of a demon and a goddess could have
definitely check out our video on the
son of Mellie Otis and Elizabeth the son
of Wrath link in the description also
please let me know what you guys think
how are you enjoying these apparent
final chapters if this really is the end
are you excited for the knights of the
round table are you expecting a
continuation or do you think that this
is truly it
Mellie Otis is iconic saute saute saute
at the end of this chapter really hit me
right in the fields not gonna lie
hit me up with your feedback down in the
comments below if you enjoyed this video
you want to see more 7 Deadly Sins
content please leave a like to let me
know it really does help and if you
happen to be new to anime uproar or you
just haven't subscribed yet please don't
forget to subscribe and hit that
notification bell to turn on all
notifications if you don't go through
the
of hitting the bell and selecting the
option that says all you're gonna miss a
lot of our videos
it's just how YouTube works you can also
hit me up on Twitter and Instagram at
anime uproar for all the latest updates
I want to give a big thank you to all of
our anime opera patrons for making
videos like this one possible with
YouTube constantly facing problems left
and right patron support means more than
ever thank you guys so much
first and foremost I want to thank our
the one tier patrons the ones who rise
above all other clans including Ingrid
ah al Olin Adam the world stealers the
school bus tyson karina acquired respect
and pat a heffa and i can't forget our
pro hero to your patrons including the
one and only Gilgamesh nothing but a fan
Jason Wilson Odin Anatoly kazansky alpha
do on hell Cruz team Sparky 65 Rohan
Kapoor cricket XP fitty dolla beat Ted
no Ted Joel - Joel Stanton very gucci
jessica calif on alicia ahktar emperor
otaku and JC c walk up if you guys enjoy
our videos and you feel that they
provide value for you please consider
supporting us on patreon even a single
dollar will give you access to our
patron exclusive discord and your name
will appear in our videos along with
these amazing people as always thank you
guys so much for watching and until next
time see us space cowboys
[Music]